so we'll talk about something very
different today very different to my
normal image filtering sort of videos
that is buffer overflow exploits and
what they are and how you do them which
is kind of fun I'm you know obviously
somewhat of a geek I quite like these
sort of things low level memory exploits
floo exploit is a situation where we're
using some probably a low-level C
function or something to write a string
or some other variable into a piece of
memory that is only a certain length but
we're trying to write something in
that's longer than that and it bent over
rights the later memory addresses and
that can cause all kinds of problems the
first thing we should talk about
probably is roughly what happens in
memory with a program when it's run now
we're talking about C programs in Linux
today just because I happen to have a
Linux VM running here and it's easier
but this will apply to many different
languages many different operating
systems so when a program is run by the
operating system so we're in some shell
and we type in a command line to run a
program the operating system will
effectively call as a function the main
method of your of your code but your
actual process your your executable we
will be held in memory in a very
specific way and it's consistent between
different processes so we have a big
block of RAM we don't know how big our
RAM is because it can be varied but we
use something called virtual memory
address translation to say that
everything in here this is not oxo or
not this is the bottom of the memory as
it were and up here is oxf F F so this
is the equivalent of 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 11
address all the way up to 32 or 64 bits
and this is naught now when you use this
there are certain areas of this memory
that are always allocated to certain
things so up here we have kernel things
so this will be command-line parameters
that we've passed our program and
environment variables and so on down
here we have something called the text
that's the actual code of our program
the machine instructions that we've
compiled get loaded in there now that's
read-only because we don't wanna be
messing about down there in here we have
data so the uninitialized and
initialized variables get held here and
then we have the heap now the heat may
have been mentioned from time to time
it's where you allocate large things in
your memory big area of memory that you
can allocate huge chunks on to do
various things ok what you do with that
it's a course up to your program and
then up here perhaps the most important
bit in some ways anyway is the stack now
the stack holds the local variables for
each of your functions and when you call
a new function like let's say you say
printf
in some some parameters that gets put on
the end of a stack so the heap grows in
this direction as you add memory and the
stack grows in this direction now that
I've laid that out we won't talk about
it anymore
we'll just focus on the stack okay
because that's where a lot of these
buffer overflows happen you can have
overflows in other areas but we're not
going to be dealing with them today I'm
going to turn this sideways because I
think it's just a little bit easier to
understand at least that's how I tend to
look at it okay so this is our memory
again nice and big this is now our stack
area excuse my program is writing up
here we have four high memory addresses
F F dot so something up here is high and
this is a X naught naught naught now of
course the stack won't be taking up this
whole region but it doesn't matter so
high memory addresses and low memory
addresses and the stack grows downwards
so when we add something on to the end
of the stack it gets put on this side
and then this moves in this direction of
course I'm talking about a stack without
telling what a stack is professor
Brailsford already talked about this and
probably done a much better job of
explaining it than I would there's a lot
of computer science depends on stacks I
sometimes think that stacks and trees is
just about all computer science is about
so we'll just save it you know house
that works and then we'll move on we
have some program that's calling a
function a function is some area of code
that does something and then returns
back to where it was before so this is
our calling function here when the
calling function wants to make use of
something it adds its parameters but
it's passing on to the stack so this
will be traveling to a and this will be
parameter B and they will be added into
the stack in reverse order and then the
assembler code for this function will
make them accorded call and that will
jump to somewhere else in memory and
work with these two things and it's the
nature of this stack that causes us to
have problems let's look at some code
and then we'll see how it works I've got
myself here a programmer isn't very good
I wrote it so it's a these are C codes
if we look at it it's just a very simple
C code but allocate some memory on the
stack and then copies a string into it
from the command line okay so up here
we've got the main function for C that
takes the number of parameters has been
given and then appointed to those
variables but you've got and they'll be
held in the kernel area of our memory we
allocate a buffer that's 500 characters
long and then we call a function called
string copy we
will copy our command line parameter
from our V into our buffer our function
puts on the return address which is for
placing the code that we need to go back
to once we've done the string copy so
that's how main knows where to go after
it's finished and then we put on a
reference to our the base pointer in our
previous function we won't worry about
that too much because it's not relevant
particularly to this video so this is
just going to be our EBP base pointer
this is our allocated space for our
buffer and it's 500 long if we write
into it something that's longer than 500
we're going to go straight past the
buffer over this and crucially overall
return variable and that's where we
point back to something we shouldn't be
doing okay so what I'm going to do is is
walk through it in the code and then
let's see if it works so this is my
karlie Linux distribution which has all
kinds of slightly dubious password
cracking tools and other penetration
testing tools it's meant for ethical
hacking let's just make that clear I've
written here a a small function that
does our copy from the command line
okay now I've compiled it and I can run
it so I can run my vulnerable code with
hello and that will copy hello into this
buffer and then simply return so nothing
happens it's the most boring program
ever another program might do something
like copy hello in there and then now
it's in the buffer they can go off and
process it yeah I mean maybe you've got
a function that makes things all
uppercase so you copy Hello off then you
change this new copy to be all uppercase
and then you output it to the screen and
this doesn't have to be main this could
be any function we're going to run
something called gdb which is the Linux
command line debugger I wouldn't advise
using gdb unless you really like seeing
a lot of assembly and really doing
low-level Linux things I love text on
the screen now so we don't to worry
about know this text here is just
warranty information so now I'm going to
type in list and it shows us the code
for our function so we can see it's just
a compile function now it knows this
because the compiler included this
information along with the executable
now we can also show the machine code
for this so we can say disassemble main
and we can see the code for main so
there the instructions that would
actually go to the CPU these are the
actual CPU instructions will be run okay
now we won't dwell on much of this
because assembly is past a whole series
of talks by someone other than me Steve
Bagley there's a lot about assembler
however a couple
really important things are this line
here sub of Oh X 1 f4 from ESP that's
allocating a 500 for the buffer that is
we're here and we go 500 in this
direction and that's where our buffer
goes to buffer sitting to the left on
this image but lower in memory than the
rest of our variables okay now we can
run this program from gdb and if it
crashes and we can look at the registers
and find out what's happened so we can
say run hello and it will start the
program and say hello okay
and it's exited normally now we can pass
something a little bit longer than hello
if we pass something that's over 500
then this buffer will go over this base
pointer in this return value and break
the code so they'll just crash your it
should just crash it - for example can
produce strings based on simple scripts
on the command line so what we do is we
say run and then we pass it a Python
script of print 41 that's the a
character 500 and let's say 6 times okay
just a little bit more than 500 so it's
going to call somewhat of a problem but
not a catastrophe okay and then we run
that and it's received a segmentation
fault now a segmentation fault is what
CPU will send back to you when you're
trying to access something in memory you
shouldn't be doing ok now that's not
actually happened because we over wrote
somewhere we shouldn't what's happened
is that the return address was half
overwritten with these 40 ones so it
doesn't know what it is so yeah there is
nothing in memory at B 700 for one for
one and if there is it doesn't belong to
this process it's not allowed so it gets
a segmentation fault so if we change
this to 508 we're going to bytes further
along which means we work now right over
writing the entire of our return address
we're over writing this ret here with 40
ones now if there was some virus code at
41 41 41 that's a big problem ok so
that's where we're going with this all
right so we run this and you can see the
return address is now 41 41 41 41 now I
can actually I can show you the
registers and you can see that the
instruction pointer is now try pointing
at 41 41 so that means that it's read
this return value and tried to return to
that place in the code and run it and of
course it can't now we can have a little
bit more fun oK we've broken our code
what can
do now well what we need to do is change
this return value to somewhere where
we've got some payload that we're trying
to give we're trying to produce okay so
luckily if I quit this Jew bugger I have
some pre-prepared payload just for this
occasion okay now in fact this payload
is just a simple very short program in
assembler that puts some variables on
the stack and then executes a system
call to tell it to run a shell okay to
run a cup the new command line okay so
if I show this code shell code okay this
code will depend on the Linux operating
system and you know on whether you're
using an Intel CPU or something else
okay this is just a string of different
commands crucially this xcd xat is
throwing a system interrupt which means
that it's going to run the system call
okay that's all we'll go into it about
this what this will actually do is run
something called zsh which is an old
shell which doesn't have a lot of
protections involved so let's go back to
our debugger and we're going to run
again but this time we're going to run
and we're going to run a slightly more
malicious piece of code we're going to
put in our 41 times by 508 and then
we're going to put in our shell code
there we go okay so now we're doing all
40 ones and then a bunch of malicious
code okay now that's actually now too
long we've gone too far but we'll fix
that in a minute
okay and finally the last thing we want
to add in is our return address which
will customize in a moment to craft an
exploit from this what we need to do is
remember the fact that string copy is
going to copy into our buffer okay so
we're going to start here we want to
overwrite the memory of this return
address with somewhere pointing to our
malicious code okay now we can't
necessarily know for sure where our
malicious code might be stored elsewhere
on the disk so we don't worry about that
or on memory we want to put it in this
buffer so we're going to put some
malicious code in here and then we're
going to have a return address that
points back in to it
okay now men we moves around slightly
when you move when you run these
programs that you know things change
slightly environment variables are added
and removed things move around so we
want to try and hedge our bets and get
the rough area but
we'll go in in here we put in something
called a no op sled or you know there's
various other words for it so this is
simply /x 90 that is the machine
instruction for just move to the next
one so that's good anywhere we land in
that no op is going to tick along to our
malicious code so we have a load of X
90s here then we have our shellcode
right that's all malicious payload that
runs our shell and then we have the
return address right in the right place
we have our return address that points
back right smack in the middle of these
X 90s and what that means is even if
he's movable it will still work so it's
like having a slope almost as it is
exactly like that yes
anywhere we land in here it's going to
cause a real problem we've got on a bomb
or our huddle oh yeah pit of lava yeah
it's a sigh Lac pit isn't it right and
you know up said takes you in and then
you get digested over 10,000 years order
for this so we've got three things we
need to do we need to put in some X 90 s
we need to put in our shell code which
I've already got and we need to put an
overturn address Y about the return
address last okay so if we go back to my
code we change the first X for T ones
that we're putting in okay we change to
90 so we're putting in a load of no op
operations then we've got our shell code
and then we've got what will eventually
be our return address and we'll put in
ten of those because it's just just to
have a little bit of padding between our
shell code and our stack that's moving
about
now this 508 here people will notice now
this is too big because we're putting in
extra information so if we write 508
bytes it goes exactly where we want over
our return address but we've now got
forty three bites of shell code and
we've got 40 bytes of return address so
minus 40 minus 43 is 425 we change this
508 to 425 and so now this exploit here
what we're looking at is exactly what I
hoped it would be here okay a sum X 90
no operation sleds the shell code and
then we've got our return address which
is ten times four bytes we run this and
we've got a segmentation fault which is
exactly what we hope we get because I
returned rest hasn't been changed yet so
now let's look at our memory and work
out where
turn address should go so in gdb it's
paused the program after the
segmentation fault so we can say list
the registers at about let's say 200 of
them at the stack pointer - 550 ok so
that's going to be like the beginning of
our buffer and what we're seeing here is
a load of 90s in a row ok so we just
need to pick a memory just right in the
middle of them so let's pick this one
let's say a B F F F F a BA ok and write
that down so I don't forget it ok now
there's a nice quirk in this which is
the Intel CPUs a little endian which
means I have to put it in backwards but
it's yet more things we have to learn
but it's fine the F F F F a put the caps
lock on and can't type when people
watching um and BA ok now theoretically
when I run this what will happen is
string copy will do its thing it will
copy a string in and then when it tries
to return it will load this return value
and execute that instruction which will
be somewhere in this buffer and then it
will read off and run our shellcode so
we should get a shell ok and we did ok
so that's a good start right we know our
program works albeit in a debugger with
very little side effect ok the question
now is can I take this and use it on the
command line to gain access to this
machine
now Linux has a Linux has quite
restrictive policies on what can and
can't be done from certain programs but
some programs such as changing your
password a run using something called su
ID so what that means is that for the
sake of running that program you are a
complete route you have root access to
that machine because I've watched how
could you change the password file
you're not normally allowed to even read
it in the shadow file so if you find a
vulnerability in that kind of program
and there's more than I think there
should be then that's when it's a real
problem now obviously these
vulnerabilities are getting rarer but
it's a catastrophic if you get one
ok so let's leave this debugger ok and
then back to our nice clear command line
environment ok so if I list the files
we've got this fundable program here is
shown in red that shows that it's su ID
boot ok which means when we run it it
will be running as root which is not
great
security now that and my shoddy
programming which means it's vulnerable
to a buffer overflow okay so if i copy
my exploit okay here we go this is a big
moment of truth right where this whole
video is going to work I've put my code
in okay this is just like it wasn't the
debugger okay I've tried to make it
exactly the same so the memory doesn't
move around let's just say Who am I on
Linux so we can see I am myself okay I
don't have root access
so can I for example look at the
password file so I can say cat so that
except to a slash shadow permission
denied no dice okay fair enough I'm not
supposed to be looking at that now I
want my exploit so MX ik my
vulnerability with the right address and
we've got a shell Who am I
root okay so now can I look at my shadow
file so root is like God for this system
in Linux there's nothing you can't do it
root okay so I've got my moot shell and
I'm loop so I can cat slash etc slash
shadow and I can see what's in the
shadow file but a point is that there's
nothing I can't do now I can wipe the
machine or do anything like that myself
and then I can quit this and then my
program does gracefully exits because
it's now returns to normal code and
hopefully no one has any other wiser but
anything's gone on now there are things
that the operating system does to try
and stop this from happening randomizing
your address your memory layout and
things like no executing of stacks and
stuff there are ways around this they
obviously for a different video but at
least things are getting definitely
better stealth and botnets usually go
hand in hand because from the point of
view of a C&C server it wants to ensure
and some years ago it seems the NSA got
a backdoor in one of these routers
presumably because they got one of their
people to get a job